the Joe Rogan experience I should have
brought in the pictures I have several
little spots yeah I'd like to see it all
over there actually in my car
where's your car it's right outside go
get it we'll wait okay I'm sure no
worries man let's go away
no worries got to see it right I mean
how often did you get a chance to look
at a dude's brain I'm scared to go into
my brain to it up but there's like
pitchforks in there and [ __ ] all sorts
of like sometimes I wonder like when I
was googling that there's a something
called Gamma Knife surgery gamma knife
surgery yeah that might is your girl
gonna go get it for you okay damage
Jamie just found you an option well I
don't know he's a doctor mr. sands as a
producer without cutting open directly I
think it's some sort of radiation
treatment oh I'm gonna look looked gamma
knife treatment need to bring you to
some witch doctor it's I mean I can't
imagine what you're going through man
and what you have gone through oh Jesus
Christ
then you go into the machine like this
what the [ __ ]
okay so folks that are just listening to
this it says brain stereotactic
radiosurgery at the Mayo Clinic and it
looks essentially like an MRI machine
and they got this guy bolted down his
head it's kind of screwed into this
[ __ ] harness so I guess you can't
move then they roll you into this
machine and what does this machine do I
think it then does this I saw this
picture video of it or this radiation
just hammers your head leaning I'll go
into this place the Mayo Clinic they're
gonna make you smarter that's what's
gonna happen with that you're gonna get
superpowers and [ __ ] how dope would that
be I came out but if you came out of
that you could read people mind would
you tell I wouldn't tell at all I don't
think I would like a mound I'd read
people's minds I just shut my mouth and
just let all these [ __ ] a lot of me
that's a crazy-looking machine man the
[ __ ] this the harness on the head
holy [ __ ] that looks uncomfortable take
up it go to that lady
lady right there with the white thing
and she looks so uncomfortable look at
her she's like I got in there my head ah
yeah tell you girls at the door okay all
right here we go we got the scans of
Rafael's brain dun dun Tom
so this this is a treatment for cavern
Ouma I was looking up cavern Ouma yeah
and this popped up I don't know I'm sure
there's since he's gonna see multiple
doctors for it that there's multiple
treatments that are going on mm-hmm
this seems to be one treatment for a
variation of it that's interesting when
you looked up like how do you get us I
just started digging digging down the
hole this is the fact that you can do
that while producing a podcast it's
quite shocking so kudos to you these are
just the pictures obviously they look
better on the disc okay oh [ __ ] I could
see it from here Wow dude that's crazy
okay folks well I'm looking like let me
hold this up so people can see
particularly this one is there any clear
that's the one on the outside look at
that of the right that is a [ __ ]
big-ass spot on your brain yeah you can
see there's a few in there but that's
the big boy but yeah all in all that
doesn't look good and that's what I saw
when I was on my way to Brazil going to
train that would especially you're gonna
shoot the box that would freak me the
[ __ ] out you can see the little ones
yeah that are around yeah they weren't
too concerned of those yet it's the big
one and a little bit of this one here
that's more on the inside it's not big
big like that one but you know all of
these are on the outside of the brain no
just some those weren't inside the brain
yeah the inside the brain so I would
scare the [ __ ] out of me that's crazy to
look at man it's gotta be weird looking
at the inside of your head and seeing
all the stuff that makes you you all
your personality your memories all your
skills all your knowledge all in there
and it's got weird spots on it [ __ ] man
yeah that's crazy as heavy it's it's
still heavy but I'm you should put that
on your Instagram
well this is my my coming-out party I
guess you could say [ __ ] man that spots
creeping me out
but you know this is hereditary thing
that you the the extreme ends or you
live with this and it's never a problem
your whole life the other side is it's a
problem right from the beginning and you
have to have multiple surgeries and bad
things happen
[Applause]